if you ever heard of unravel then it's
almost certain that you know about the
game's hero he's a wool wrap doll called
Yanni who as far as heroes go is just
delightful he's an adorable silent
quaint little creature Yanni is about as
big as a kitten but he seems far more
fragile because he's made only of cable
wire and yarn because he's so flimsy
he's scared of pretty much everything he
jumps when he's approached by a
butterfly he's absolutely terrified of
cars when he's crossing the road his
eyes which are two big white dots of
wool are just wide enough to seem like
he's permanently startled he doesn't
have any of our facial features as my
mouth no eyebrows and the cheekbones and
yet he's animated so wonderfully that
you can get a real sense of his
character you can tell he's pretty
adventurous for a coward the way he runs
of his arms aloft the way he swings
across platforms he does this things
with a sense of determination and
derring-do he's basically the little
engine that could and it's genuinely
hard to resist how charming he is the
more you control him the more he wins
you over unravels developer a
sweden-based studio called cold would
interactive has put yarny at the center
of the games publicity campaign and that
definitely makes sense I asked five
other people at gamespot to tell me the
first thing that came to mind when they
thought of unravel and the majority
responses was how cute and charming yani
is I recently got to play the games
first two levels at preview event hosted
by its publisher EA and i have to say
going in I was a bit worried it would be
a familiar story you know was sort of
dainty and thuy in the game that had no
real substance beyond this but from what
I played I was particularly impressed by
two things festival let's talk about the
world of unravel yani was born as a ball
of red yarn that one night fell out of
his owners basket as she walked upstairs
for bed it's a very tell like set up
similar to Toy Story you know things
that magically come to life when humans
are out of sight what makes it work so
well is how much detail and dedication
has gone into designing the world that
surrounds yani unravel presents this
eight
ception alee detailed depiction of life
just that ankle heights rugs become
massive stretches of carpet the size of
football fields kitchen tables are these
onimous wooden stadiums something as
simple as a concrete step can become
like a boulder that's very hard to climb
over if you ever looked under your bed
or sofa and suddenly found yourself
gazing at how different the world looks
from floor level then you're going to
really enjoy exploring unravels world
that leads me to the second thing from
what I've played so far unravel is a
finely tuned puzzle platformer that
creates very smart challenges from
everyday items you honestly won't
believe how much thought has to go into
opening a shed door if you're only eight
inches tall let alone climbing over a
garden fence as Jonnie moves the twine
he's made of unravels a bit like a trail
of breadcrumbs so if you walk too far
without finding any more twine he's
reduced to this gaunt wireframe figure
and he can't walk any further this means
you need to explore the world to find
hidden pieces of wool and you have to
actually figure out how to collect yarn
that seems a bit out of reach but that
weakness of the irony is also his
strength he can also use his wall to do
a manner of different things such as
abseil down giant drops or swing across
platforms Indiana Jones style he can
also fast in his yarn on two knots of
wolver scattered throughout each level
which sort of helped him create a whole
manner of tools from rope bridges to
makeshift trampolines unravels
challenges encourage this kind of
experimentation of mixing different
tools together actually there's there's
also a third thing the music unravels
creative director Martin salen believes
that for a game of zero dialogue music
is one of its most important
storytelling tools music is the voice of
the game he says the soundtrack was the
first thing in unravel that I totally
fell for it's a kingly melancholic at
times it's charming and relaxing others
it works beautifully for a game laced
with nostalgia as an air of sadness and
mystery and that works ideally for the
kind of story that unravel is trying to
tell having played the first two hours
of unravel signs are positive so far it
may star in a door
homemade creature of wire and wool but
behind its charming exterior is a
challenging puzzle platformer that seems
to have all the fundamentals in the
right place gamespot's review of unravel
will go live monday februari 8th a day
before the game's global release
you